hi my name is Nick Hughes non-committee  services manager at that district  council the council has a helpful and  friendly Democratic Services team part  of whose job is to help and support all  councillors and answer any queries they  may have we provide a comprehensive  members induction for all of our  councillors covering all aspects of  being a councillor to get you off to the  best possible start in your role in  addition we also provide member training  throughout your time as a councillor  which is tailored to your individual  needs this covers both how the council  works and soft skills such as speed  reading assertiveness and ICT skills